[Norvig] Now let's put the whole thing together.
I've defined zebra_puzzle. It's a function.
It doesn't take any arguments because there's only 1 puzzle.
There aren't different puzzles that require different arguments.
It's going to return a pair of WATER and ZEBRA,
so 2 house numbers indicating which house drinks water and which house owns a zebra.
I've repeated houses = [1, 2, 3, 4, 5] and I've also defined first and middle.
I've repeated the work of figuring out all the orderings. That's constraint #1.
And then I've written the whole function as a generator expression,
and I chose to do that rather than sticking with the nested for loops
just because the structure is a little bit easier.
What we're doing here is we're asking for the next version.
So in other words, the first time through we're asking for the very first solution
to this iterator expression where we say iterating through the 5 properties,
if each of the tests is true, then return the values of WATER and ZEBRA
and then keep on doing that for all possibilities.
But I'm only interested in the very first one, which the next after nothing is the first.
So go ahead and return that.
Each of the constraints is very easy to state.
Englishman is red, the Spaniard is dog, coffee is green and so on.
We have some immediate rights and nextto, and that's the whole problem.
So in some sense we have a solution; in another sense we know that it's going to take
something like an hour or 2 to complete.
And maybe we're not happy with that, so we're going to make it faster.
But before I do that, I want to do a little bit of review of these generator expressions
because probably you haven't seen this too much before.